that's a kind of eugenics attitude
hitler had a very eugenics attitude
uh wanting to get rid of uh not just the
jews
but uh he he killed his own people first
with euthanasia
he killed a lot of the people that he
thought were a burden on society
the elderly the infirm the disabled
he had euthanasia policies to get rid of
them
he started there even before he started
sending the jews to the concentration
camps
to die he started with those people in
his own
nation who he deemed to be not worth
uh continuing to live so this elitist
attitude
of killing off those who they decide
have lives that are not really worth
living uh is eugenics that really fits
in with
a kind of satanist attitude to
the weak and the infirm which is get rid
of them
or exploit them get rid of them or
exploit them
it's very elitist satanism is very
elitist
so you often hear people referring to
the global elite
uh who
many of them are satanists and they are
pushing a satanist agenda
for the globe so
epstein was into this in a more than uh
just an average passing interest to the
point that he
was even a speaker at some of these
conferences on eugenics
and that kind of suggests that
he had an interest in common with
satanists on this
ultimately satanist would like to
enslave anybody who's not in their camp
and treat them as slaves and
will regard them as slaves uh and
inferior to them
and will kill a lot of them as well
offer them up in ritual sacrifices
uh this is the ultimate
goal in the satanist agenda
for for the globe for the world
uh that's part of their global agenda
it's about the strong exploiting the
week
it's about the strong getting rid of the
weak it's about the strong and slaving
the week
now you talked about you've recently
talked about a new world order
is that what you're explaining right now
and just to add to that before i forget
they sometimes brand like your brand
cattle in the u.s
right they will sometimes brand their
victims to show
just how subjugated and serbian their
victims are you're my
property and are brand new like a
capital
uh and that brand will stay on have you
seen with these brand
these brands on people uh the
sra survivors i've met so far have not
had those brands
but i know i have colleagues on
sra who have met such people and
interviewed such people
talking about their branding and
it's a sign of their attitude of course
the branding itself is horrific but
it's a sign of the attitude towards
their victims that you you're nothing
more than
than a slave or even worse than a say
just a cattle to me
a piece of meat a piece of meat and um
that's how i regard you and you must
know your place you must stay in your
place and know your place as a slave
and you will always be my slave
and there's no way you're going to get
out and they want them to believe that
of course
so that they never try and leave and of
course there are lots of threats to keep
them in
and even more threats if they dare to
ever
expose what happened to them uh so
this new order that you mentioned i i
often point out that
when you talk about new world order you
should mention the word satanist before
it because
because newer orders occur at different
points of history
for example after world war one
the map of europe had to be redrawn
because various empires
had lost lands or gained new land
as a result of the res the
world war one conflict
and so uh
that was a new world order that was
not a satanist new world order but there
was a new world order
so the term newer order itself is quite
neutral
and it's not necessarily bad after world
war ii there was a new new
order cold war united states on one side
ussr on the other uh
eastern europe under the soviet bloc
western europe under the u.s
influence that was a new
new world order from the first world war
new world order now we're going for
another new world order but this
is different far darker than the
previous new world orders
this new world order is a satanist
dominated
new world order that is being pursued
uh and it's going to be if
it it manages to implement itself it's
going to be
basically enslavement um
which would have been the result if if
the nazis had won for example
the second world war right it would have
been widespread enslavement
they were enslaving the people that they
occupied but this would be even worse it
would make the nazis probably look like
choir boys by comparison
if the satanists get their agenda
fulfilled
of their new world order then you will
order would
include having the power of life and
death over large
numbers of people and we're already
seeing more and more of that
with practices like euthanasia
and assisted suicide and i know that
satan is very much
support such practices and if you if you
are implementing those practices with a
eugenicist
attitude like what the satanists have to
get rid of those that they deem to be
not worth
living then what you have is a pretty
efficient killing machine
and so this new order that's being
pursued
uh at the core the core beliefs of this
new world order
it's not fascism or socialism
that's all kind of uh
window dressing yes there are elements
of
fascism involved there are elements of
socialism involved
but under that the real
substance of the belief system
is satanism because
as you probably know the satanists
believe
that
they are going to have a one world
government
in the not too distant future and that
one world government will be
ruled by their version of
a messiah their satanic messiah
the antichrist that's what they believe
whether you believe it or not they
believe that and they are working
hard to pursue that and one very clear
example of this was when the satanist
organized in june this year rallies
calling for one world government to be
established
they had several rallies in the u.s in
different parts of the u.s calling for
one world government
to be established it shows you how bold
they're getting because they didn't try
and disguise the fact that they were
satanists they just openly organized it
and called for one world government and
they did it in some other countries as
well
they need one world government in order
to obtain
world influence and domination
they are not going to use the
old-fashioned way of
invading country of the country to build
an empire across the globe because that
will take years
and that will not necessarily succeed
lots of people have tried like hitler
and napoleon and didn't succeed
so they're trying it in a new way get
people to
believe that it's in their interest to
sign up for one world government
get people to believe that there are
some global crises that cannot be dealt
with
other than with one world government
for example the covet 19 pandemic
which at least one senior uk
politician said we need one world
government
to deal with this and uh
that kind of show that was a glimpse at
what the real agenda is
building around this have a global
crisis get people
scared about their lives about their
their way of life and then offer the
solution one world government everybody
of their own accord signs up to it
thinking this is a good thing
then get their person their leader
the antichrist as christians would call
him
or satanic savior as perhaps the
satanist might call them
call him at the top of that one world
government
then automatically you will have
satanist domination
over the world because he who leads the
one world government will lead the world
so we've got to be careful about this
thing about globalism which i think your
current president is very rightly
opposing because globalism is going to
lead us
down the road to its one world
government oh let's all work together
oh we're going to have global crises
like this kobe 19 pandemic
we need to have a one-world government
to deal with these kind of global crises
um on the surface it may sound
attractive
but underneath that you've got to ask
questions
who's going to lead the one world
government what's going to happen to
your national sovereignty
are you going to have to give up your
independence eventually you will have to
give up your independence because the
one world government will trump all
governments
so this is the
satanist global strategy and
from their one world government they
will be able to enforce
satanist objectives agendas across the
[Laughter]
world